I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense they flew me to Vegas and I
became Diana Ross's opening act and the
audience hated me I was horrible like I
had nothing I had the rubber glove I
have pictures of myself onstage at
Caesars I'll tell you that that Caesar
story so I'll and
I landed Caesars yeah you know and I go
backstage at Caesar's Palace on the
doors my name Howie Mandel when I got
with two L's no but it didn't matter you
know everybody knows my games my name
right tilted stilted today it's okay but
it's not too else it's six everybody
could tell so I had my name shortened
for show business but and a guy comes
and says we need you to do 20 minutes
tonight and I said okay he goes do you
understand what I just said I go you
said you need 20 minutes he goes do you
understand what I'm saying I go 20
minutes he goes not 21 not 19 oh wow
that's what I thought oh wow how do I do
that and now today I'm wearing a watch
but I didn't
I don't wear watch I'm only wearing this
because it's got like a Fitbit on it but
I don't I don't wear jewelry I have not
no no watches and I go how am I gonna do
that I know what I'll do so I gave some
guy backstage 20 bucks if I would work
in front of the curtain and she had her
whole Orchestra behind the curtain and
the reason they wanted at 20 is because
her show was perfectly timed and at that
time it was more about the getting out
to the casino so she did an hour and I
did 20 that's 80 minutes and then boom
the people were not there Caesars Palace
didn't care about people coming to see
Diana Ross they want the people to come
to see Diana Ross lose all their money
to gamble right and in fact you are
sitting in front of that booth right
there is the center both users oh yes
I'm Caesars the original Caesars they
tore down that room to make the
Colosseum which they built for Celine
Dion oh yeah but the original Caesars
Palace Circus Maximus showroom - yeah
that's the center booth that's the booth
that was in that room when I played that
so anyway I gave a guy 20 bucks and I
said okay just when it's 19 minutes bang
on the that doesn't sound like the floor
that's a table but bang on the floor
behind me right behind the curtain
and I know in one minute I can take that
glove out I'll close with the glove over
my head and blow it out
so I anyway the first night starts and
though the lights go down the audience
roars you can hear the announcement
ladies and gentlemen Caesars Palace is
proud to present an evening of Diana
Ross and the crowd goes crazy and if you
listen really closely and I was probably
the only one that did you can hear but
first Howie Mandel you know and I walked
out on the stage and just - I'm sorry I
keep hitting the table just to the sea
of disappointment you know this is not
what they paid to come see this is not
what they want to do and I only worked a
lip at the stage and the people sitting
on front in the front of the stage would
I look down and they would be pounding
on my toes on my shoe and I'd look at
them and they'd go they'd mouth get the
[ __ ] off of mic because they came to see
they pay big money see Diana Ross and I
was this lowly comic that was just
acting silly and going okay what what
and you could see I have a picture my
wife took a picture of me on stage I'm
wearing a sports jacket you could see
the sweat stains through the sport I'm
just you know then finally after what
seems like an eternity of silence you
know I I hear boom boom boom on the
floor behind me and I go oh my god
that's like the saving the best sound
they've ever heard yeah so I'm gonna
close with the glove and I take the
glove and i inflate it over my head and
it's still silent you feel stupid when
you're saying things and nobody's
reacting of course standing in front of
a group of strangers a couple thousand
strangers in the rubber glove on your
head and it's just silence and I'm
thinking I just pray this is like
double-double with latex maybe they're
roaring I'm sure they're all laughing
and it pops off my head and it just
silence and people are looking at me and
then that's it finally I got to say
ladies and gentlemen enjoy Diana Ross
and they roar again and I turn around
and I try to get through the curtain the
the guys supposed to page the curtain
for me yeah and he's holding it closed
from the other side and the applause is
dying down and it's more quiet and more
quiet and more coy and I can hear him
going
what another ten another ten oh my god
and I Turk that's what usually those are
the words from inside my own mind and I
turn around and the audience is just
sitting there going what's happening and
have to do another ten I have
more material I am soaked I blew up the
rubber glove and I go dude who's here
from out of town and sick and then
finally I hear boom boom boom again I go
goodnight and they let me through the
curtain what would it happen this I'd
only done ten minutes I was dying
somebody walked by somebody by backstage
that wasn't a signal I'd only done ten
minutes
oh my god and she wasn't ready to come
out total truth time goes this so slow
and you're suffering
yeah and the thing was that every night
I went on they hated me nobody enjoyed
me nobody saw me one night sony rented
out the whole room there wasn't a person
sony from japan that there wasn't one
person that did you know which was
probably the best idea and though
because they liked the gloves that's the
one thing they loved but every night but
Diana Ross would stand there was one
left you know how they say if he could
make one person laugh well I didn't know
this she would laugh at the sides she
would laugh and then after a week I get
called into her dressing room after go
thank god they're gonna put this me out
of my misery she was gonna fire me and
she she sat me down she goes gonna talk
to you and I go yeah good plan ready
please just release me she goes you are
so funny I love you and I would like to
offer you the whole rest of the run
[Music]